today we have Vinod Khosla founder of
Khosla Ventures and Palmer founder of
Sun Microsystems
he has advised a lot of startups in
Silicon Valley I'm going to interview
winnowed today and we're going to talk
about how to build and manage teams
thank you an eternity so you've talked a
lot about company building and hiring
and I know that you've often said that a
company becomes the people it hires not
the plan it makes so can you elaborate
on what you mean by that
and especially for founders who are just
beginning to start a company like what
should they focus on in hiring yeah this
is one of my favorite topics many many
founders and in when you start you know
very little about what you're doing if
you did know enough you wouldn't start
the company if you were really sensible
and pragmatic you wouldn't start
companies I have an on no ships delat
has self-described and I'm a real fan of
people trying companies and trying to
build things especially when you're
younger when you can afford to take the
risks there's no reason to go work for
somebody else my book and and I never
did what I find is people have plans but
it is really very rare for a company to
achieve that plan so the way to think
about where you're starting is a
collection of ideas in a relatively rich
space that you find you can be
passionate about that's the way to think
about the plan and now the separate talk
on flexi planning which is don't plan
just plan to plan but the critical part
of that is the team you build ends up
making all the iterative decision
about where you're going to end up
whether to hire the next person from
this area or that area with that
strength or some other strength or to
pick path a or B is very very critical
to where a company ends up there's a
huge fast dependence and the path
depends so much on the people you hire
your starting plan becomes much less
relevant than the people you hired
initially especially the first ten
people those ten people will then go on
to hire the next 50 and they will then
hire the last 100 you can hire the
original team and it's gene DNA stays in
the company so that's why it's so
important and why the people you hire
determined the company becomes and we
can come back later and talk about where
I see mistakes made around functional
hiring people always ask me and I say
this gets tweeted a lot there's a huge
difference between a zero million dollar
company and a zero billion dollar
company and the difference is attitude
and ambition and mostly the kind of team
you built which will reinforce certain
directions for you especially who else
you end up hiring so it's all more
critical than people believe and it's
very hard to hire that those skills
later so that hence my yeah and I think
you've touched upon the first and hires
becoming it being so important and
especially defining pretty much even the
culture or the belief system that you
would call for the company so if the you
know a lot of founders here have like a
one of team two member teams how should
they think about you know who should be
those first few hires and how do they go
about finding those candidate
and I know you also have talked you have
a strong view about how equity should be
split for the first ten employees versus
the next thirty so I would love to hear
like how to the founder think about that
so many startups are very tactical and
they should be but in doing the tactics
you can sometimes forget what the big
vision is and you may even exclude the
big vision so I was talking to a company
fairly recently in our portfolio and
that hired a bunch of people to do
particular tasks that needed doing and
there was a new hire potentially a big
hire very attractive person to have
joined the team and I asked the founder
who's going to interview him and he told
me who would interview this founder I
said if I was a really great candidate
and these three people interviewed me
first I drop out of the recruiting
process so I said you know what why
don't I be the first end of your so that
can be a real waste of my time because I
want him to grab the big vision first
and not just being interviewed let me
sell him on the big idea and why he can
be a part of forming it and so the best
people almost can't be interviewed they
have to be sold and evaluated
evaluations important bit of evaluation
and interviewing at different things in
my mind so once you hire the first five
and they interview another people you
might actively exclude the best
candidates and and that's very very
tricky for a founder at the same time
sometimes you can't afford the big name
so you don't have enough to attract them
and those are very tricky times and
that's why I think whether you're zero
million dollar company or zero billion
dollar companies order get set by the
time you're 15 or 20 people
that people who have done it very poorly
I won't give you examples but people
like stripe Patrick did it amazingly
great job of his early hires and has
continued to do that so you can
completely change the trajectory of a
company by that hiring in how big you'll
become okay what are some of the things
that you think Patrick at stripe or some
of these successful founders have done
in the first year is it that they need
to continue candidates and other roles
because the founder often also doesn't
know a lot of the other roles or doesn't
have domain knowledge about you know the
rules that they are looking to hire so
let's start each about about each of
those separately because they're quite
distinct types first I think of company
building as going after Mount Everest
but nobody got to Mount Everest without
getting to Basecamp first here's the
misstep you can't get to address without
Basecamp and many people forget that
Basecamp has to leave to Everest
so they set up base camp where it
doesn't help reduce the risk to Everest
and so building a company you never
shoot for the big enchilada in one step
you go after Basecamp London Basecamp -
it's a very good analogy however
especially with bad investors and I have
a lot of beefs about investors they want
revenue or they want breakeven or the
one management all the things they can
lead to setting up business here that it
then excludes the possibility that you
learn more about how to get to Basecamp
two and three you are out in some other
local minima or Maxima and that's really
dangerous early on - in fact one of the
beefs I was just talking to somebody in
the YC class and sort of talking about
this I said and this one of my advices
of advice - I say
if you get too tactical and forget the
strategic you set up base camp in the
wrong plans so you don't you want to
sort of decide which is the rich space
you want to go after with the technology
in this case starting with a great
technology before you start doing all
the tactical stuff so there's this
uncomfortable balance between tactics
and strategy I say be obstinate about
your vision be flexible about your
tactics another way I'd like to say it
is think big but act small these are
really difficult things to navigate much
easier said than done but back to this
issue let me talk about a process I call
gene pool engineering if you going after
a space assuming you pick the right
space or the one you're passionate about
it doesn't even have to be the right
products right for you the first thing I
suggest people do is say all the ways in
which you can fail think about it you
want to identify the key risks in
whatever you're trying to do then you
hire for those risks so always say to
people find your top five risks for each
of those risks say risk one who are the
companies that have dealt with that risk
or where does expertise on that risk lie
make a list of three to five companies
and by the way this document you'll get
a link called gene pool engineering
that's on our website that I wrote just
for this purpose if you've identified
the five companies that have dealt with
that risk then you have a tease the
places that can reduce your risk within
each company identify three names now
you have 15 names for the risk number
one if you do that for your top five
risks you essentially have a library of
that will help you reduce the risk in
your business and that's risk oriented
management and startups after you decide
what space you're on going after is all
about risk management there's lots of
risk trade-offs every time you hire
somebody you increase your bond you're
taking on financial risk but you're
reducing some other risk
maybe it's product risk or development
risk or feature risk so it's a series of
trade-offs
that's how startups should think about
what they're trying to do so this is the
process I call gene pool engineering
where you engineer 15 names for each of
your major risks and then go after all
of them and hopefully hire one or two of
the 15 and so you've been engineered the
gene pool of your company or the risks
that are in the plan you're going to
pursue it's way more precise than the
platitude of let's hire great people I
find that really disturbing because I've
never actually had a start-up coming to
me and say that they're only hiring bad
people never quite happens so how do you
make platitudes into something concrete
and actionable that's a big thing with
me um the second part of that is the
reality that startups seldom pursue the
original plan they started with so
they're hard you also have to hire not
only for the risks you know but all the
other things that you might give it to
change to adapt to iterative because
building a business plan in a new area
is a series of iterations so suddenly
this risk requirement goes in parallel
with this other requirement which I call
smart adaptations you adapt very quickly
to whatever the market is teaching you
and why she is particularly good at that
teaching you how to iterate quickly and
learn and is
actually very similar to what I call
this flexi planning process where you
iterate your way to a plan instead of
saying this is my plan I always worry
when people make plans seven years out
and give me forecasts because it tells
me they don't have a clue what they
don't know and and that is one of the
great benefits of YC from my point of
view this iterative approach other
people call it MVP or there's other
names for this iterative approach I call
it flexi planning but the team you build
in addition to this risk approach also
has to be open to new ideas
grab new ideas ask a lot of questions
adapt quickly brainstorm with others
constructively so you build on each
other ideas these are parallel setup
requirements around hiring that are very
hard to quantify they're also full of
danger they are full of danger for the
following reason sometimes people don't
hire for these that's the danger at
other times and one the biggest risk if
you decide you want to be aggressive
about hiring is going after names or
titles or other things big names and
titles in big companies are really
really dangerous and misleading for
startups my biggest mistakes early on in
my career was getting into impressed
with somebody's title at IBM or some big
company now I take the view if
somebody's been at a big company for 10
or 15 years if they're mean at Cisco for
10 years they can't work effectively in
a start-up to Liggett Rhee brainwashed
by failing once or twice in the startup
then it'll look so hiring for this other
stuff in not falling into the trap of
just big names is very important also
depends upon your domain if the domain
you're your startup
is radically different than your Acura
doesn't let me put it differently some
domains need a lot of expertise so if
you're doing a blood cast like Tara
knows you can drop out of school and
start that but eventually it's a serious
physics and chemistry problem and you
have to get that talent on board if
you're doing something like striped it
it was a very simple problem you don't
need three PhDs if you're going to solve
healthcare with AI you're going to need
expertise so it depends on the domain
you don't always need the Guru's it
depends on your problem you don't always
need the big names another very
counterintuitive thing we were
recruiting for a CEO for our company
alive for they essentially do cardiac
care and I insisted I would not talk to
any candidate who would ever worked in
health care and that's because
healthcare executives tend to apply old
rules because the domain hasn't changed
very much people are so used to applying
old rules and applying good process as
opposed to inventing this new future
this new path and that's very dangerous
we should come back and talk about how
founders should figure all this out when
they don't have a clue what these other
functions are that's really dangerous
and so that's a big big caution it's
seldom that a person out of a domain can
innovate in a domain and if you're a
young founder and you hired somebody
with deep experience in a domain it is
logical as human beings to deform or to
their knowledge and that is a real
problem
it's important to understand the
problems they raise not the solutions
they propose because if you take that
you keep doing what traditional people
in that industry have done this is why
CEO hired into companies don't work very
well and by founder vision becomes so
important than so critical I'm wandering
all over the place but correct yeah no
this is hell I think you also before we
touch on the functional heading and how
to look for domain knowledge I wanted to
touch upon one other element that you
talked about in the gene pool hiring
paper which is about diversity and not
in the literal sense but he talked about
there are different dimensions of
diversity that are important as you're
trying to figure out candidates can you
elaborate on like what are the different
dimensions of diversity is not up should
really focus on and why is it important
to do that early on yeah
so if you buy the thesis that most of
what you'll end up executing on isn't
part of your plans today then the single
most important thing becomes people who
can help you evolve your plan and the
more diverse the set of people and I
don't mean diverse ethnically I mean
backgrounds in places they've worked
areas they know age level of experience
there's some really great things about
experience you want experience but you
don't want experience to have you guide
you into doing what others have already
done in that same business and not in a
weight that is the result of too much
experience so mixing the right
experience where you can identify the
problems with first principles thinking
from fresh new ideas people who've never
worked in the domain or people who
actually are just fresh graduates and
have no idea but can ask fundamental
questions those are the best kind of
founders put
differently in big companies you need
people with good process in startups you
need people with good iteration and good
adaptation and and those are very very
different skills because in startups you
invent 90% of stuff in big companies 90%
of what you do this year will be what
was done last year so there's very
little innovation takes a different kind
of person both valuable in fact every
startup if they're successful will need
some process people later but process
people early in a startup can be a
disaster too good a manager is the bad
thing for these startups but at some
point you really need to add that so
that's what I mean by diversity if you
have a bunch of PhDs how many are
experienced PhDs and how many are fresh
how many are from within your area and
how many are from completely outside the
area those every dimension of diversity
will help because they'll bring a
different point of view as long as they
have this ability to think from first
principles not say this is done this way
because we did it this way before
I should also sort of probably say this
feels way more complex this was written
about it extensively in two articles
once called the art and science of
hiring you'll get a link to that it's on
our website too once called gene pools
engineering there's a third one actually
row 23 boy joined us which talked about
what board shouldn't shouldn't do boards
more do more damage to startups than
anything else I know and that's why I
don't go to board meetings anymore
what Allah applying tradition just
really hurts so when you're looking for
an investor it's not money it's helping
building the steam that's way more
important way we're more important where
you get to then anything around the
amount of money raised or the valuation
or other things we should come back and
talk about founder equity also but I
spend a third of my time maybe more time
on recruiting for our companies than any
other single thing I do because of all
the things I've talked about in fact
that startup grind he the the
interviewer asked me he said Jamaat was
saying then you couldn't possibly spend
that much time interviewing and I said
that's because he just kind of angry has
a different belief system than me I do
and it's most of what I do I I'll go to
a hundred LinkedIn resumes by myself on
a weekend if I'm looking for a critical
hire for a company because a few people
can make up or break a company yeah and
I think you've talked about this too
which would be helpful here like the
CEOs job initially used to be the chief
recruiting officer right so it can be
real a berate on what is the founders
role and how should they be thinking
especially because we see a lot of
startups where they say oh I'm looking
for VP of Sales and they write down all
the skills but then they forget about
all the elements needed for what it
takes to lead it in a starter yeah so
let's come back to this notion
functional hiring let me talk about what
fungus needs to get a founders role and
when I was a founder I spent probably
40% of my time recruiting it's not
coding you're much better off hiring the
people who can code then coding
you throughout the life of the startup
or it is both in the beginning and
throughout the life of the startup I
think it's true a very early mid stage
and later stage companies and really
good founders do most of that because if
you can hire the people you should
generally be able to hire the people who
can do any given job better than you can
and I tell founders about their role if
there's any job you can hire for modulo
money which we can talk about you should
hire for that role so you don't have to
spend on how does have some unique
characteristics they have to this are no
real spirit this first principle
thinking this attitude says yes done
this way but why this why and I
recommend a book by simon Sinek called
start with why it's a really good book
about questioning everything and and yet
staying true to your vision even if it's
not precise if you're doing something
radically new it's going to be ambiguous
and very very few normal people are
comfortable with that ambiguity let's
charge your head in this direction even
though we don't know precisely what the
business model is or why or what we'll
take that that leadership is a fungus
role in that something it's almost
impossible to hire for if you hire a
senior executive from another company
the zero chance you'll have that they
can systematize what you're doing and
get more much more boost to your efforts
but not without your vision alright and
so that's a founders role I call it
leadership it's belief system in the
face of ambiguity it's figuring it out
kind of attitude assembling a diverse
team I was very lucky as a young founder
I love
awesome people I didn't know why I
rehired many of the people but if you
look at it the first 15 people we hired
that son probably started more than 10
companies for two billion dollars later
on you know we hired Carol Bartz who
became CEO of Yahoo be hired Eric
Schmidt who became CEO Google's he hired
all these we hired builder of joy - joy
became a founder six months after we
started we should come back to it I so
badly wanted him we made him hunger
retro actively I anything is okay in the
game of assembling great talent I loved
learning from gay people so we hired
great people in retrospect that was why
we were successful and I started
believing company becomes the people you
hired by the way Andy bechtolsheim was a
student in Margaret Jack's Hall not far
from here where the computer science
department used to be and he'd license
his technology to six companies the only
one that succeeded with it is us and we
started two years after some of the
other companies that licensed the
technology but we got all the people I
how did Andy till he dropped his PhD to
join me i hounded bill joy till he
dropped his PhD to join us so both of
them dropped their PhDs when they
thought there were six months from
finishing selling is also found us
jumping and it's gut-wrenching because
you don't know you're going to be
successful you know trying to convince
somebody to drop their PhD it's it's
gut-wrenching hiring is gut-wrenching
are you convincing them to drop a
comfortable job at Google and join you
so many stories anyway back what were we
talking about yeah no I think just to
read I know before you've said in one of
the points that when it comes to selling
for hiring no means maybe and the
maybe means yes I have my favorite and
it games it says no I convinced them it
them maybe then I'll spend enough time
once they say maybe then my job is to
say maybe it's a yes so always there
knows or maybe and maybe is a yes and it
doesn't matter if you fail occasionally
when you succeed it's what people give
up and recruiting way too early and way
too quickly I just hung people I've
already just one founders equity because
I'm a brother duck slide so how should
you know especially when you're trying
to attract you want to build a great
team rather than a great tea has a
magnet for other you know people to join
the company how to founders think about
equity especially in the you know the
early hide yes
so I find by and large and there are
exceptions plenty of them founders keep
too much equity for themselves and they
don't realize the follow falling fact
anyway anybody they hired whose
exceptional will a year later figured
out they want to start their own company
unless they're a founder okay so if
somebody is really so you self-select
for okay people good people not awesome
people so my son starting a company
actually two companies right now he
graduated last June from Stanford and I
convinced them that him and his
co-founder should just take fifteen
percent each leave 15 percent for a
third pounder another fifteen percent
for three junior founders and then a 20
percent pool after that so they have
this humongous pool I said because I
fundamentally believe a company becomes
the people it hires I said you'll be
able to hire great people so for one of
his companies and I think this is public
it's not stop recording he
hired for one of his companies the VP of
engineering of korah
why would that person join a fresh
graduate because one he helped define a
fairly interesting large vision but two
he had this huge book and he's been
talking to people who would take that
kind of thing any of whom could start
their own company
let me invert it when and say when the
team comes in to present to me one of
the questions I ask myself in judging
how good a team ends yeah do they have
expertise in all the areas that need
expertise but the single most important
question asked on this team if some of
these people left and started a company
would I want to invest in that company
if somebody has two people like that on
their team zero chance I want one I
invest independent whether I like the
plan or not because they're collecting
great talent if I could have great
talent or a great plan I'd rather have
great talent in somebody a founder who
loves great talent so it's a great way
to judge a start-up is what kind of
people do they hire I was telling I do
and I told Sam
in the last YC batch there was two
companies we made an offer to if they
hired in a critical area the words AI
startups if they left co-founder equity
equal co-founder equity for an AR
startup said I'll write your check at
the valuation you want if you do that if
not then we don't want to invest what if
I'm to cut off and the other one didn't
which is okay but I really religiously
believed this idea you get a bill joy or
Andy back to time and the world
experience they were graduate students
but they made the whole company Eric
Schmidt wanted to come work for them and
by the time he had first ten people we
were getting so many resumes everybody
wanted to join us because we had so many
awesome
people other than I was sort of me and
McNeely with just fresh business school
graduates we didn't count I would say
and I keep telling my son hire some
magnets the people I tell them you
graduate from Stanford you're young
nobody's going to come join you just to
work with you all right think about who
you could get that everybody wants to
work with that's how you'll hire that
numbers 10 through 30 or 50 yeah a rough
rule of thumb I used on equity I think
Sam has said at least 10% of the company
should be reserved for the first ten
hires I actually think that numbers too
low I flip it around 7 accompanies 50
the founders should have a third of the
common their direct report should have
so if there's five or six direct reports
should have a third of the common and
everybody else the engineers the worker
bee should have a third of the common if
you do that people don't leave people
stay with you now
Sam has a good blog post on how to
attract the team one of those is growth
growth is always a metric but you can't
always close that when things get tough
when you run into trouble why will
people stay they'll stay because they
believe in your value system what are
you going after the vision you're
defining define an interesting ambitious
enough vision if your vision is just to
make money the people who at the first
dip will say oh I joined to make money
doesn't look like it they'll leave they
won't stick with it but the single
biggest reason people stick with the
company is because they have people
around them who are really awesome that
they can learn from who are better than
them everybody should feel that way
that's a great culture to set up and
every time I've seen that done it's
turned out
really well the gene pool engineering
article I mentioned I put together in
1995 when we were starting juniper
nobody had ever challenged Cisco and
nobody wanted to challenge Cisco and no
customer in the world wanted to buy TCP
IP routers none for the public network
it sounds in crud was but go look up
articles from 1995 not a single carrier
AT&T photo stack bel ver eyes what is
now Verizon all said they would never
introduce tcp/ip in the public network
and we defined this large vision we
built this process of engineering the
gene pool of the company and everybody
got excited about changing the course of
the internet from what was ATM and
nobody remembers this but a very very
senior executive told me when I was
looking at investing in this they would
never use tcp/ip this is what telecom
carriers do this is how traditional
wisdom goes but you need this awesome
team to change that and pradeep's endo
who's the Stila was one that great
founders have run into not only built a
great company but it actually changed
the trajectory of the protocols for the
Internet in my view we would have ended
up with something else
most likely ATM if all the carrier's had
their way every single carrier from
Deutsche Telekom in Europe to 18d here
had decided they would go with ATM not
tcp/ip so great missions great people to
work with all that is why you want
people in your team got it and I want to
touch upon functional highly because
that's I think it is a component of
building a great team as well and too
often founders tend to prior there's a
lot on skills for a particular role
versus really figuring out you know the
the complete package or the set of the
project it's okay
talk about how should I found a thing
about hiring so let me answer that
question yeah but later if you're a
founder you just you're technologists or
have a break technical breakthrough or a
big idea and you start a company and you
need a VP of Marketing or you need a CFO
we should come back to the question and
I cover this in my art of hiring how you
judge somebody is good VP of Marketing
at a good CFO because the first thing
you have to realize is you're not
qualified to judge knowing what you
don't know is critical and one of the
most important things a founder does is
decide whose judgment to trust on what's
stopping and not just ask their friends
because they may not be qualified in
fact Congress has hired their friends
into a green food engineering a startup
and that's wasting slots and talent too
but let me go back to functional hiring
we can come back to this otherwise I
cover it fairly extensively in my paper
on hiring how do you interview people
how do you judge them if you need a VP
of engineering you can look at somebody
who's managed an engineering project but
if you're a founder especially an
inexperienced founder with a big
breakthrough idea in a new space that
nobody knows you clearly need to build
an engineering team and execute on that
wood you need more than that somebody
who's going to go help you evaluate all
the pivots and changes and iterations in
your plan now let's say you hire a VP of
engineering who's good at that a VP of
Marketing who's good at marketing a VP
of Sales good at sales and CFO and they
do their job well who's going to help
you figure out what path to take
so I always say you need functions but
way more important while hiring those
functional people you're getting
something else whether you recognize it
or not you're getting somebody who are
going to participate in all the more
critical decisions even more critical
than having engineering run smoothly
which is which path should be tight
so ask the following question when I
hire a VP of engineering how will it
make my VP of Marketing better that's by
asking fundamental first principles
questions Elon Musk's book is worth
reading that he knew so little about
building cars about or about launching
rockets he made so many scream mistakes
that could have been avoided but if he
had had all that experience and
knowledge you won't even have attempted
what he did and so I'd rather have
somebody like land mass who just
fundamentally asks a lot of questions so
why are we doing it this way not that
we've done it this way for 50 years at
GM remember GM spent more money more
time and started earlier trying to do an
electric vehicle called the ev1 and
alone with no experience by asking a lot
of questions in adapting rapidly AG
screwed up he got to a place where Tesla
is a much more interesting company than
GM today so when you look for that
functional higher realize you're also
getting this other thing which is much
more important look for how they think
how fast they change how how much they
become defensive and you challenge an
idea versus saying oh why didn't I think
of that or be much more brainstorm
oriented this sort of horizontal hiring
that you get while doing functional
vertical hire
is much more important than a much more
important dimension and by the way most
Reese's don't look for it
because they've not gone through
building companies themselves so they
give you bad advice the number of times
they say go get somebody with
distribution channel expertise I'd
rather had somebody figured it out and
not have a source of inertia in this
fluid dynamic evolving thinking method
in the company so when you are hiring
more than anything you're hiring a brain
trust and they happen to also have
skills in doing functional jobs but the
brain trust more important than the
functional job and evaluating them is
very tricky and it's tricky because
partly you don't know how to evaluate
somebody outside of your area of
competence do you call a VP of Marketing
at Cisco I don't mean to pick on Cisco
but it's a good company to pick on they
will look at marketing very very
differently than what a start-up needs
so they will give you the wrong advice
going through and this is where the
tricky part comes not being overly
swayed by titles or positions and
understanding why people did certain
things and how thoughtful were they
about it what did they do that wasn't
usual is very hard it's also tricky to
go back to this question of how you
evaluate people most experienced
interviewees know how to give you the
right answers they're going to fool you
you ask somebody what did you do here
they'll retroactively we look at what
was great about the strategy and say I
did this I've actually had people pitch
me and what why they did son's marketing
strategy
being very very indirect kind of a list
of questions in my paper on hiring the
way you get to the bottom so I always
for example give you one example I'll
ask the same thing three different ways
I'll say at the beginning what do you
love doing what are you good at somebody
to say something then while talking
later about a Java said what did you do
really well there if those two don't
coincide if somebody's making it up they
want I'll ask that question three
different ways third time I like Adam if
you were to join this company what would
you think your strengths would be I've
asked the same question three different
ways in three different context people
who are making it up will make up
different answers people fundamentally
have the truth will give the same right
answer then I might at the end of the
interview ask so what will be a boss say
about you now that's the same question a
fourth time if they say something then
I'll say hey can I get your last
performance review that you Boston if
they say no I know they don't want to
share their performance I have a hundred
tricks like this I use you can never
rely on the direct answer you get in any
ring somebody it's the trickiest thing
and then it's good to get together with
each other and see what each person
looked at one other danger in hiring I
find like if I'm rushed today and I'm
interviewing somebody I'll evaluate them
differently than if I'm doing it over
coffee on a Saturday morning
all right so other thing to keep in mind
depending upon how you your day went or
what mindset you're in how you evaluate
people changes so four critical
positions all interview the same person
three times at three different days just
so I'm not biasing myself because humans
including yourself
open myself are really biased and and so
there's so many pitfalls this is why
doing a start-up is so hard anyway I'll
let you ask more questions REI keeper
anywhere I could go on for six hours
I'll ask one more question I'm going to
open it up for Q&A so I know you talked
in that paper you have you have a lot of
questions and we will circulate that for
interviews but you also make the point
that in spite of even if you follow all
those processes you know mistakes are
inevitable and at least one-third of the
time the hires don't work out what if
your view is like the most common reason
why the hires don't work out and how
should have found a handle that because
sometimes startups wait too long to sort
of figure it if somebody wants a job in
the interview their job is to fool you
alright
the question is are they better fooling
you or are you better at getting behind
the words I find after hiring many many
people now probably do hundreds of
interviews every year I have a success
rate of about 65 percent okay I'm wrong
and I find most people with less
experience are wrong more often because
usually if you're a young founder the
people you're interviewing are more
experienced than you act fooling you so
it is a game and we didn't talk about
culture and other things that those
reasons why came dates fail but there's
really not being able to get behind the
scenes in dig deep so one you are a plan
on that happening I always tell my teams
if you want four people on your team
hire six even make up a title you don't
need yeah sure
I always over hired because you're never
successful and hiring is a long process
to hire critical person in a start-up
whether it's a technology critical
technologist or the senior executive can
easily take six months or longer and
then they take six months coming up to
speed so if you've made a mistake
you lose the year and they will have a
hard other crappy people during that
time and so it's really very expensive
this way you really need to watch new
people you've won so you need to really
evaluate how they're doing and this is
where I think board members and
investors should be much more about
assisting the venture so I never call
myself a venture capitalist I say a
better assistant and so even our tagline
for our firms in venture system I like
to do all this and spend all my time
doing all this I never go to we see
functions so I I never go to financial
conferences I just spend my time with
founders and people there trying to hire
and by the way it's a lot more fun and
you learn a lot more and get excited
about it but you should over hire
flipside if you find somebody great make
up a title and hire them two things no
great talent is worth getting away
because you don't have a slide make up a
slide they will pay for themselves the
flip side with feud's options and there
are some nobody a great talent is never
too expensive to hire so I've gone
all kinds of ridiculous things we are
trying to hire an exact today and I was
arguing with another VC this morning I
said so his company offered him this
they're about to go public
why don't we guarantee him the first 15
million dollars out of this startup I
give him a preference or the preferred
stock I'll click go to any lens for
great talent huh nobody heard of putting
50 million a preference for an employee
above the preferred stock that the
investors money but I've done this more
than once so a couple things around that
the flipside is plan for failure and
evaluate new people one other thing you
can also when you hire somebody and I
want to stop try and assimilate that
people can fail because they're the
wrong fit but people can also fail
because you didn't assimilate them well
you have somebody really experienced in
a business and you hired somebody from
that business they can advise you on how
to assimilate this person because you
might think of what they're doing
differently than somebody who knows that
in person or that business so getting
advice and how to assimilate people into
your business because they are going to
be different they are their diversity
you're trying to be and you don't want
to be too uniform so it's getting help
in assimilating getting lots of advice
and how to make them successful as
opposed to reacting because they're
acting so differently in doing things so
differently that's bad too but then of
course if you make a mistake you have to
be quick and your investors can good
investors can help you do that
that to me is the principal value good
investor spring anyway let's open it up
to questions questions for a few minutes
so you talked about
based rocket and pizza and then turn off
set out that Gaza and why do you think
both of them are cause you're out of why
they think Madison is required with the
main expertise and then one after the
other
well different questions one I think
strife hard really awesome things in
fact the stripe co-founder that is now
running open AI right so he hired
somebody so strong even though he was a
college dropout Patrick right he hired
awesome people around him
I don't think telling us did this early
there's a culture thing we didn't talk
about and culture is very important I
think good companies acknowledge their
problems say what do we need to solve it
and tell us early on tried to hide their
problems they didn't encourage
discussion around their problems and I
think that was the difference I think
Elizabeth has learned a lot I think if
he was to do another startup she'd do
much much better but sometimes in trying
to show other the outside world
you're a great startup you tend to not
acknowledge your weaknesses and that's a
danger in fact most startups spend way
more time on their assets not their
liabilities your liabilities can kill
you faster than your assets can make you
successful so you need to spend time you
need to have open because you're a
cohesive group generally when you're
starting out you tend to have group tank
so you tend to lose sight of your risks
and and you want to encourage that
behavior of asking a lot of that culture
we won't go too much into culture today
but establishing the right values why
people are
here what the mission is what kind of
culture and none of our people made the
point having good goodies in your lunch
menu isn't culture you know allowing
dogs in your workplace isn't culture
though I love dogs culture is about
fundamental values and how you behave in
what you encourage in the more people at
every level in the organization can ask
questions the more you will identify
your risk sooner have a more
constructive culture and the more likely
you will increase success let me finish
that by saying one other thing Sam said
something else that I really like he
said startups are a pass/fail game they
put everything I've been saying in
context I like to say startups not about
dilution they're about the probability
of success they're much more digital
than you think and you can increase the
probability of success by hiring great
people by asking a lot of questions but
not finding your risks early by having
people surface problems you're going to
increase your probability of success and
either you're successful or you're not
and and so it's about probability now
and people worry way too much about
dilution and not giving more equity to a
co-founder or new-hire we may need to be
made a co-founder I'm seeing a lot of
this in the AI startups now there's
there AI startups but they don't hire
the AI Callen because hey the average AI
person that Google machine learning
person is making the median income I
think it's like $750,000 cop what you're
going to do to get that person you can
pretend you can do without that but
you're pulling yourself sorry there was
a question there um
this earlier and you spend you started
is going to resume so for for like early
stage can you quickly go to like a 30
seconds one meaning where you look for
if you're hiring let's say probably our
technical or like the early business
dead person what do I look for first
people who can think originally about
their area whatever their area is
LinkedIn completion it may be in the
color you know internship if I ask
somebody what what interesting papers
have you read in your area of expertise
if it's narrow diversity tells me one
thing if the broad diversity it's one of
my hundred questions hours the district
question like what books have you read
or what it tells you how they think and
that's critical to start up in addition
to knowing encryption algorithms and you
tell me when yes cough I'll keep asking
probably the last one so they sort of
that's food shopping you set value and
leveraging technical advisors on
advisory board there is always value in
leveraging technical advisors in
advisory board what's important is to
get their opinions but not respected too
much this is a game this quandary which
is hard
you want them to surface the issues but
us the founder using first principles
one let's say do I believe this or not
or how much should I weigh this versus
some other things that's the critical
part that's the hard part
that's what makes entrepreneurship hard
because it is it is a lot of fun but
it's really hard to I have a great
presentation I that I came up with the
title in 1986 and still on our website
the entrepreneurial roller coaster where
the highs are high and the lows below
and the lows are really low in every
start up that's it well thank you so
much without for taking the time thank
you everybody
[Applause]